some of the Silicon Valley's biggest
investors are being asked tough
questions about the world that they
helped create over the weekend to major
investors in Apple Jana partners in the
California State Teachers Retirement
System sent a letter to Apple urging the
company to do more to fight smartphone
addiction among young people
Roger McNamee co-founded Elevation
Partners he was an early investor in
both Facebook and Google which is a
great thing financially but now he says
he regrets some of what those companies
have become Roger Beckman joins us
tonight Roger thanks for coming on my
pleasure it's kind of amazing to even
begin this conversation with you
considering you so famously made great
bets on both those companies and now you
you're concerned about what they're
doing explain your concerns it's really
simple Tucker the the problem that we
have here is that many of us and I count
myself among the number have viewed
technology as one of those things that
was only goodness yes there really was
no downside to it and for the longest
time that was true now because
smartphones are available 18 hours a day
and because companies like Facebook and
Google have personalized two billion
individual channels so each of us has
their own programming all the time
addiction is actually an inevitable
result of their advertising business
models yes and it's not something we saw
and I personally look back on this and
I'm kicking myself for not having seen
it at the same time I've committed
myself full-time with my partners
Tristan Harris and others to to try to
start a national conversation about what
is the appropriate role of Technology
what is the best way to protect our
children and I'm delighted to see that
there are large institutional investors
who are bringing their market power to
bear to try to call attention both to
the issue and to provoke companies to do
the right thing so I assume you still
have at in the peninsula and the in that
in a day area how unpopular are you I
mean this is the most countercultural
thing you could do I would think well
it's it's a really interesting thing
because I think you're right for the
longest time the Silicon Valley didn't
want to believe that there was a problem
I mean everybody likes disruption
because it's easy what they don't want
is to bear the consequences of having
done that disruption and now that
they're being called to task what's
really really cool I wrote
thing in the Washington Monthly this
past weekend that that brought CEOs to
me to start conversations for the first
time so you know I'm not worried about
popularity that's not what this is about
I'm really worried about our children
I'm worried about the country I'm
worried about democracy I'm worried
about what goes on in the world I just
think that we don't want to be made more
lonely we don't want to be made more sad
but I don't want to be make more
unsuccessful we for sure - what that
happening to our kids so what do you
think the right way - and you're saying
this is a very informed unusually
informed person on this question how is
it the best way to manage your
children's use of these devices so I
think the really important thing for
every parent to understand is that there
are a lot of bad things that can happen
here I mean we think about products like
YouTube kids we think about products
like snapchat these are products whose
business models are designed around this
notion of addiction by the kids and
they're just not prepared to deal with
it so parents need to restrict usage of
these products in fact one of the sad
things Tucker one things that makes me
angry is that executives out in the
valley
generally restrict their kids usage of
the products that they are encouraging
everyone else to use with abandon and so
I think the first thing to do is you get
explain to the kids hey guys there's a
lot of bad stuff going on here and it's
not your fault and you know I wish we
had caught this before to become an
epidemic problem it's it's amazing
you've said it makes sense it seems
obvious for our viewers who don't know
who you are I would encourage them to
Google you because they will see that
coming from you this is profound you
really are with this right and then this
was a huge change for me I'm well I mean
it's amazing I'm proud of listen this is
my national service right now I'm well
it's amazing that you're doing it well
I'm grateful that you are Thank You
Roger and let's keep the conversation
going you've got four girls we got to
take good care of them okay any time